bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale les
championnats du monde féminins 2016 ifan
ou face à maria amouzou qu neuvième
partie maintenant que la chinoise mène
de deux points et qui reste que deux
parties dont il suffit d'une match nul
avec les blancs une partie nul suffit
pour remporter le titre remporté ce
titre qu'elle a déjà gagné plusieurs
fois donc il reste au noir là par contre
a joué le tout pour le tout on sait pas
fasciné des sévillanes et avec les noirs
à ce niveau là de la compétition mais ça
peut arriver c'est déjà il ya quand même
des fois des retournements meybon fo
d'en gagner deux en plus sur des cales
gagnent et en plus la dernière mais
pourquoi pas total va tout tenter et
puisque sinon le match s'arrête donc
c'est parti avec eux 4 pour iphone qui
ne changent pas à 100 ouvertures fétiche
du match 4 c'est ce qu'elle joue le plus
souvent comme on n'a rien d'ailleurs ces
alors voilà donc la lgv harry parce
qu'elle a beaucoup joué dans le match e
voilà la réponse symétrique là c'est la
première fois elle tente une ouverture
plus tendue kabis iii que les c6 des 4
je comprends qu'il prend cavaliers m6
calais c3 tout ça est normal et des six
voilà alors là on aurait pu jouer aussi
navarrenx technique off avec eux scène
directement dans cette position peut
aussi jouer eux 5
ces coupes sont préparatifs scène
directement ce cas le câble ibm des cinq
ans b5 ici et il attaque la classe des
six menace call it be six échecs fou
prend dans prend on a éliminé un flux
important des noirs et alors
ici des six c'est pas la même faut 2 est
maintenant de 5 ce qui fait que
maintenant si on joue qu'à elle et les
indécis s'est déjà défendu par le fou
déjà bien sûr mais aussi par la dame
maintenant puisque le pion n'est pas en
dix-sept la case et le pion dont sont
défendus et donc sur calais des scènes
pour jouer à six car il ya trois baies 5
et aux menaces de fourchette ici voilà
et donc c'est pas tout à fait pareil
donc avalé b3 voilà c'est pour ça qu'ils
évoluent jusqu'où la fossette
petit rock petit rock foo 3 normal il
faut six voiliers qu alors le problème
des noirs dans cette position c'est la
casse des biens sur des scènes qui est
arriérée c'est pour ça que le coussin
qui à la fois bien parce que ça permet
d'aller vite de développer ces pistes
rapidement ça a chassé le cavalier ça
contre la classe des cats mais mais ça
laisse le pion des six en arrière ce
pion des six qui n'a pas de collègues
pour le soutenir et qui se retrouve
devant une classe des ce1 qui est déjà
contrôlée par le pion ici puis 1,4 le
cavalier et la dame
donc on rajoute du côté noir du contrôle
sur cette case qui est une case du
crucial qui est un poste de d'invasion
pour les pour les blancs f3a lorsque ou
f3 est simplement dans l'idée de pouvoir
jouer un jour cavale et des 5 parce que
tôt ou tard les blancs vont jouer
cavalier des 5 et dans ce cas là le pion
aux 4 il faut le défendre puisqu'il est
il est attaqué par le par le cavalier m6
voilà donc f3 simplement est un coût qui
défend e4 tranquillement et qui laisse
aux fous sa liberté parce que venant si
on défend avec le fou bas ce fou serait
extrêmement passif qu'on le mette en d3
en d3 se seraient pas bien le sens
relève du contrôle de d5 ici et en f3 il
serait très très mal placée devant le
pion f alors ce pur f
on sait que c'est souvent un pion
cruciale notamment pour l'attack donc
alors là il est en défense mais plus
tard en un parti pour jouer
4 voilà l'idée d'un f3 je protège le 4
parce que tôt ou tard de calais des
scènes que ce sera à l'ordre du jour
cavaye à 5 alors pourquoi pas
bon alors c'est sans doute un coup
normal qui se joue mais alors moi j'aime
pas trop ce coup parce que on a le
sentiment cette position me trompe
peut-être mais que ce cavalier quand
même qui mieux mieux placé plus actif
que celui là je suis là il déjà est
bloqué par ses 5
il est bloqué par cinq en c1 qui peut
pas bouger
donc il est un peu museler alors que lui
il est un peu plus d'air ils peuvent
venir en d4 éventuellement il pourrait
je sais pas plus tard venir un set une
fois que ça bouge je sais pas donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il est quand même un peu
bon mais pourquoi pas travailler à 5 ont
cavalé prend d'impro et maintenant dam
des deux voies là tranquillement les
blancs encore une fois c'est pas la
première fois dans ce match qu'on voit
ça finisse leur développement en liant
les tours voilà on met la dame sur une
bonne case à noter qu'elle est protégée
la dame par le fou donc une petite
menace ici qu'il faut connaître un
positionnelle c'est de jouer le coup
qu'à aller des 5
parce que dans ce cas la dame des deux
hommes attaquent la dame à 5 et 6 les
noirs prennent bien on joue d'abord
cavaliers prend fut un échec
wabush et après je prends la dame qui
fait j'ai gagné une pièce au passage ce
qui est une très mauvaise nouvelle donc
attention à ces un petit piège
positionnelle sur calais des cinq du
coup les blés noirs peuvent apprendre
oublié de revenir défendre le fou on
prend le fawcett et lors des six n'a
plus de défenseurs alors là là c'est
l'horreur les blonds la paire de fou
décisive à sauter ça ce serait un
désastre
attention donc voilà typique c'est le
coup alors c'est un coup classique qui
part à cette pseudo menace ici tours fc
8 maintenant en cas de cavale et des
scènes qui toujours possible d'en prend
cavale et prend échec roi f8 tout
simplement il faut reprendre la dame ici
on reprend le roi prend le cavalier on
récupère la pièce il n'y a pas de
problème si c'est le roi maintenant qui
défend le pion aussi des six les les
noirs en plus ça tacle pioncer 2 il n'y
a pas de problème ils s'en sortent très
bien et dans une bonne partie
donc ça marche pas ici
cette combine donc voilà ton rêve d un
tranquillement donc on rajoute ici du
contrôle sur la classe des scènes
voilà toutes ces pièces empêche le coup
libérateur des cinq wife 8 voix la bombe
et voyez donc on le voyait dans la
combine conques ont envisagé mais on le
joue on peut le jouer aussi tout de
suite un petit un petit contrôle sur le
fou tranquillement on se rapproche un
peu du centre c'est toujours être utile
et a4 alors voilà le plan des blancs
dans ce dans cette position le plan des
blancs va être d'essayer de monter une
attaque de pions sur cette aile ici
alors c'est pas simple puisqu'il ya
quand même les noirs contre la colonne
sais mais bon il faut profiter du fait
que ce pion des six est arriérée mal
placé fossé dans de prendre de la deûle
avance ici est de donc de prendre de
l'air donc ce poids cadets j'apprends un
peu d espace à 6 du nord pareil ici déjà
on verrouille cette case dessin depuis
ce qu'on pouvait craindre des caraïbes
et celle des choses comme ça qui propose
un échange de dames qui attaquent des
six pour faire attention encore une fois
et voilà qu'à l'été cinq autos ou tard
se le dise ce coût est à l'ordre du jour
ça y est à noter que en jouant ce
coup-là ya la découverte par contre il
ya plus de cas elle est renflouée cheikh
intermédiaire ici on peut prendre la
dame tranquillement pourpre en cavale et
prend très important quand le cavalier
tandis qu'on laisse pas faire prendre le
fou puisqu'un escalade et si ces faibles
tout là tout le reste de la partie on
élimine ce cavalier tant que le fou
protège pourquoi ça oblige les blancs à
prendre du plomb donc les blancs
reprennent du pillon et c'est fini au
sens c'est fini ce n'est pas fini mais
la partie est finie mais c'est fini en
termes de problèmes sur des six ce
pionner plus faible puisqu'il ya un pion
blanc devant les blancs ne l'attaquent
plus donc le fos étaient libres de
bouger le fou 17 va jouer bien sûr là
ils jouent en 17 a tranquillement
il un kit oeil sur sur à 4 il a il a un
petit oeil sur b5 parce que peut-être
que le noir veut jouer b5 eux mêmes et
voilà les noirs ont une position
correcte ambiant ils n'ont aucun
avantage pour gagner pour gagner ça va
être plus dur
un petit rhume donc là c'est parti à 5
classique le cou à ce n empêche
définitivement bessin comprendra un v6
en passant l'a noté que b6 et contrôler
aussi par le faux 3 et donc ça ça serait
un très mauvais coup des 5 propose les
échanges de fond et voilà même idée bref
huit adhérents f1 tac
pourquoi parce qu'en cas d' échange des
noirs eh bien je gagne du temps je
ramène le roi plutôt qu'à les prendre en
b 5 qui ramènera un pion vers le centre
qui empêcherait les blancs a jamais de
jouer ces cas puisque le pion b5
contrôlerait cassé quatre qui en plus
permet au noir d'attaqué à cinq bon bref
ce serait pas bon de prendre non
simplement ramène ici et on va jouer on
va menacer de jouer des plans à base de
baies trois c4 le fou à être chassés à
moins qu'ils s'échangent avant mais si
s'échange à venger ramener le roi vers
le centre f 5 ans les noirs maintenant à
eux ils ont une majorité de pions autant
les blancs ici regardez ils ont un deux
trois quatre pions contre 3 majorité
donc d'où l'idée d'attaquer deux
scooters et alors que de l'autre côté et
noir ont un deux trois quatre pions
aussi contre 3 voilà donc l'idée des
noirs c'est de mettre en mouvement
leur majorité de pions noirs à l'aileron
ces trois tranquillement se presse pas
alors s'il est si les blancs avaient
joué un coup comme b3 pour menacer ses 4
je suis pas sûr mais probablement comme
coup comme tour c3 et bloquant attaque
le fou et on peut pas venir attaquer la
tour et là ça bloque le pion ces deux
c'est ça le problème
ça bloque le pion ces deux donc quand on
va doubler les tours on va vraiment
attaquer ces deux et les noirs
l'initiative donc ça c'est pas bon ça
serait pas une bonne nouvelle pour les
pour les blancs donc regardé comme les
prudentes du coup lifan elle joue
d'abord c3 elle va protéger ses trois
essais une fois que ces trois sera
protégé le jour à b3 puis c4 d'aller
voir sa manoeuvre c'est très joli g5
alors même idéal et non y vivant il n'y
a pas d'autres plans pour les noirs et
je vous rappelle qu'ils doivent gagner
là on est en championnat du monde
neuvième partie on est mené 2 points il
faut absolument gagner donc de toutes
façons photo actifs sert à la limite les
coûts sont presque forcée et à tour ces
deux voiliers comme ses patients mais
tranquille pour ce que je protège ses 3
et maintenant je vais pouvoir jouer b3
c4 je crains pas la manoeuvre tour ces
trois alors les noirs auraient pu aussi
peut-être joué des coups comme tour ses
sept au lieu de g5
si on revient en arrière ici peut-être
ici un coup comme tour c'est 7 suivi de
tours c'est 8
dans ce cas là même si à tour ces deux
on peut pas jouer des trois puisque ces
trois aspects emprise
j'ai dit à mon avis ça gêne pas vraiment
parce que je tour ces deux quand même et
après on sera fou d2 tout simplement la
food & de sa surprotège c3
ça a l'air ça a l'air lourd de faire ça
mais ça marche très bien en jouer b3 et
une fois qu'on a un jour on aura joué
ses cartes on sera vraiment tranquille
bon bref donc ici j'ai cinq tours c'est
le très solide
donc là après h5 mais voilà elle mais
elle met en avant sa sa majorité de
pions la cca c'est clair je crois que là
c'est visuellement très nette
et maintenant voilà c4 maintenant que la
tour alors le nord aurait pu changer
d'abord le fou de la vente du joueur 5,6
là aussi peut-être on fait d'abord faut
prendre 2 et ensuite on fait h5
on aurait pu aussi avec les noirs
activer le roi edouard vii pour essayer
de le dollar a reproché un peu un peu du
centre avant de démarrer bon pourquoi
pas bon c'est quatre attaques le fou
tout cas et là j'ai quatre voilà on
craint pas bien sûr il n'y a pas de
prise puisque la tour pour l'instant la
tour la tour seront prises donc on peut
jouer g4 et maintenant b4 voilà
tranquille bk parce que les blancs il
aimerait jouer ces scènes tout
simplement
mais oui j'ai un fou là qui protège très
bien cette case et puis j'ai une fois
j'ai joué c'est simple j'ai presque un
pion passé je joue j'ai vu qu'un échange
les fous je fais ces six tombes et 7 bat
tomber du coup le pion à 6 sera passé
soutenu par un tour le pion 6,6 aussi
j'aurai deux pions passé ça va être
difficile à l'impôt les noirs là on voit
que la majorité blanche là ça commence à
être à devenir dangereux f4 alors les
noirs aussi et s'est activée ça c'est
normal ou f2 contrôle très bien là tout
ça n'y a pas de pas de problème de foot
il n'y a pas de pas de gros danger pour
l'instant ici c'est même si les pions
soit avancée n'a pas de tour derrière
y'a pas il n'y a pas grand chose mais
c'est quand même très très bien défendu
un coup de blanc n'y a pas de pas de
faiblesse et la food & cette voie là fou
17 parce que peut-être que les noirs
auront envie de jouer des coups comme
h4h 3 des choses comme ça bon problème
c'est que si on joue h 4 on va se
prendre prend peut-être pas d'ailleurs
pas si on joue à quatre si on prend j'ai
4 sél autre pion qui piquent et libre
attention e4 et là on induit option qui
devient menaçant avec sa peu dangereux
aussi dans les deux sens et plumes qui
avance trop ça peut être faible mais en
le faisant ça me paraît fort donc si on
pourrait jouer h4 et en cas de prise en
jouant eux 4 et a tout de suite ça y est
c'est plus la même et il se passe des
trucs alors les blancs neutre c'est pour
ça que les blancs qu'ils ne traînent pas
pour attaquer de leur côté s'étendent
pas que le noir après l'initiative c5
donc là on voit les deux côtés comme ça
qui font la course pour essayer de créer
les premiers les premières menaces font
f5 bien bien joué attac la tour pose la
question tu vas vous contrôler la case 4
on a vu qu'il ya des idées de leucate
aussi qui peuvent arriver donc les
blancs les noirs a moins bien joué que 4
d'ailleurs parce que quatre ça fait une
pression maximum sur f3 et si les blancs
prennent mais je prends et là c'est
dangereux c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux commencé à voir des choses on
a envie ensuite de bouger le roi a mené
une tour en face du roi adverse et il
peut se passer des choses pour ces
quatre voilà s'explique le coup je
contrôle la case 4
pas de problème en cas de 4 je prends et
le fou ne peut pas reprendre
et voilà roi f7 pourquoi ben je ramène
le roi près du centre ce qui n'est
jamais mauvais et et puis pourquoi pas
une tour qui pourrait maintenant
envisager de coulisses et quelque part
là ça pourrait créer des menaces tour d
1 ha alors celui-là alors tour des uns
peut être dans l'idée que si les noirs
prennent en c5 je peux pousser d66
présence et celle des six soutenu par la
tour et l'appui depuis ce pion il
devient très très fort tous les 8 voilà
toujours aux mêmes idées pour les noirs
pas de problème tu fais ce que tu veux
moi je continue mon plan j'attaque du
côté droit j'ai poussé mes pions
maintenant je commence à ramener mes
pièces lourdes et b je vais peut-être
venas et les choses j'ai trois alors les
blancs bloc parce que là peut être que
les noirs menacé eux-mêmes de jouer de
jouer g3 qui j'ai 3 h prend f prend le
fou doit bouger et puis c'est l'autre
pion qui avance et on commence à avoir
des idées de pions passé là avec des
peut-être des combinaisons possibles qui
menacent de faire dame les choses comme
ça donc il faut faire attention
donc j'ai trois ça bloque ce type de
l'idée un peu plus jamais jouer jusqu'à
4 ici il ya prise voire même on bouge
pas en fait on ne bouge pas on essaie
d'éviter au maximum on prendre plutôt un
g4 ont d'abord ah oui à kiev 4 l'emprise
attention là un aspect on prend un f4
puis on prend et tout reprendre
donc là faut que les noirs réagissent
donc pris mon projet 3 et presque forcé
à cause de la tour qui attaque et f4 h
et maintenant tour assez vite voilà
c'est l'autre tour qui jusqu'ici était
passible qui maintenant vient remplacer
la tour s'est vite qu'ils étaient
conscients qu'ils étaient venus en g8
est remplacé par la torah
voilà on peut donc on peut prendre mais
il y aurait peut-être en échange de tour
intermédiaire
hélas pions projet 4h plongée 4
et maintenant projet de voie là
tranquillement tranquillement donc là
l'attak noir de ce côté-là a été
complètement bloquée par des coups
précis ou au bon moment alors que la
pression blanche allèles dame elle est
toujours là il ya toujours cette
pression ici il ya se fout d'eux qui
vise un peu le pion à 6 alors il est
protégé ici par 17 mai les blancs
pourrait jouer des coups comme ces six
ces six semaines aspirent prend 17 et si
les noirs prennent on prend de la tour
et on voit tout de suite que ce soit à
cassis voilà donc tout ça est faible
parce que c'est sous la ta kwai et de
ses deux fils et de fouet notamment le
fou de cases blanches mais même le foot
canon a ainsi joué un rôle voilà sur la
casse c'est celle sur la case b6 et
voilà donc c'est difficile alors que
voiliers a pas l'équivalent du côté du
côté noir ni côté droit pour les noirs
donc si difficile à là on voit pas
comment les noirs pour avoir des chances
de gain les bleus ont fait aucune faute
et noir bien tenté de monter une attaque
mais elle est repoussée assez facilement
l'impression food et cette petite menace
peut-être fou b5 et enfin échanger
souffre ou peut-être il aurait fallu sur
l'échangé quand c'était faisable parce
que là on voit que ce fou joue contre
ses deux pions et peut-être pas les
laisser les fous de cases noires
tout rachat voilà sept tours a fini bon
le travail qu'elle faisait là est donc
ici bas elle menace de venir en recettes
elles menacent voilà de prendre la
colonne ici puis d'embêter les noirs
tout simplement dont j'ai cette logique
j'empêche tout simplement tournage c est
bon c'est un peu comme une caste pas
siffler à la tour est moins libre que là
puisque là elle pouvait coulisser sur la
sueur de ce côté là mais là elle peut
plus elle est bloqué par trois pièces
dont elle n'est pas près de se libérer
de parler de l'autre côté et elle est
que passive au sens où elle défend g4 à
un g4 qui a attaqué par le fou par la
tour par des a contrario cette tour
comme elle est active au sens justement
elle fait pression sur g4 et en même
temps elle le soutient la puce et c5
puis on prend des six c'est l'heure pour
les noeuds pour les blancs fou prend
pour prince et à 8 fou prend 6,8 et la
mauvaise nouvelle poussée 5
problème le foot attaquer
on a un pion passé pour les blancs en
dessin il ya aussi un pion passé pour
les noir e 5
mais on voit bien que c'est quand les
blancs qui sont plus actifs se fout et
passifs fini en défense cette tour une
passivité en défense se fout il est
passif il est en défense et alors toutes
les pièces blanches elles sont en
attaque et rien ne sont pas en défendant
qu'il ya que le roi presse qui protège
le g3 et encore parce qu'il n'est pas
plus
voilà en tout cas là il ya un problème
sur sur des six il faut réagir et puis
la torah chien qui active va venir
enregistrer certainement très vite c'est
à dire classe il est noir joue un coup
comme l'imaginent on sait pas ce qui a
été joué imaginons recettes mais
simplement regarder tourache 6 et voilà
qu'est ce que je fais tu pourrais faire
je vais pas je vais pas mettre le front
ses sets ça parce qu'il ya des six
échecs au roi et sa gamme le fou et
s'ils vendent et 8 s'est pas beaucoup
mieux
s'ils vendent des 8 il peut pas avoir
mieux joué et ça se peut pas bouger
donc j'ai dit n'importe quoi il peut pas
bouger du tout et s'il prend mais là on
va avoir deux pions de pions de pions
très fort ici on attaque contre l'europe
donc ici après fou csn bay les noirs
sont rhésus se résolvent à apprendre
tout de suite quitte à prendre autant
empêcher tout rachid quoi voilà
puis on prend et maintenant fou et funk
à non petites petites menaces quand même
c'est une petite combine échec enfilade
sur la tour est en même temps un échec
je prends le pion des cinq ans qu'on se
dit baye a pas de solution si si si une
solution simplement wild 2 voilà wild 2
parce que maintenant si les blancs
attaque la tour et le pion mais
simplement la tour vie en d1 et ça
protège très bien donc tour g8 de la
part des noirs
3-3 et tour des huit
alors voyez comme malgré l'égalité
matériel si vous comptez des pions
quatre contre quatre
on voit à l'oeil nu on a l'impression
même que c'est les blogs comme un pion
de plus parce que ce pion aux cinq qui
est le pion qui équilibre le matériel
pour les noirs il fait rien il menace
rien isolé alors que ses deux pions ils
sont ils sont liés voyez la force des
pions lié pionniers se dire si leur
avance il est protégé par l'autre donc
on peut menacer ses six parfois on peut
menacer des six pour courir vers dame au
bon moment voilà donc c'est beaucoup
plus fort et qui plus est le pion
bessette il est ce qu'on appelle
arriérés ceux qui ont 17 et en arrière
est bon on peut pas venir en b un psy
quel fou mais on peut imaginer tour d un
tour d2 et puis un jour tour b2 et il
est attaqué et on voit bien que ce fou
qui est sûre case blanche il aura envie
de venir par exemple en g2 et rajouter
la pression là-dessus c'est bon c'est
dur quoi c'est très dur donc là déjà on
sent là que les carottes sont cuites
pour pour les noirs touré fin superbe
clouage alors pourquoi elle fait ça
parce que a priori une toux sortir du
clonage bien sûr on est obligé
d'ailleurs 3g 6 sort du cloud âge tout
en protégeant le fou si on avait joué 3
m6 ont perdu une pièce fou détroit
aurait psy fou détroit le flou et s'ils
ont joué quatre fous prend et le foulée
et toujours cloué donc il y aura tout
reprend et chacun voilà qu'on croit g6
et le confort c'est alors secoué loi ne
le roi des pions donc enfin petit ce
petit coup pour éloigner le roi est
juste après up tour des 1 donc en fait
on en bijoux est tournée tout de suite
mais le roi aurait été horrible 7
c'est pas pareil bref cette île à un peu
plus près des pions que quand j'ai 6 3
et 5 et la d61 on y va c'est l'heure
alors des six plein problème hein mais
je suis pas loin dam d'un premier point
et deux jours
aussi cette grande diagonale qui tape
sur b767 tombe à 6 va tomber aussi donc
se fout il va se régaler la suffit juste
qu'il arrive à trouver sa bonne case à
l'oref un g2 dur
donc là les noirs tente un dernier truc
tourache 8 pour essayer de créer une
invasion côté droit de menacer les
choses pas de problème on regarde et dit
fan calcul et elle a joué assez vite
c'est cool a d'ailleurs j'ai pu voir
cette fin en direct et le jouée avec une
facilité une rapidité qui ont alors
qu'il lui reste trente minutes à la
pendule donc vous dès cette menace de
faire dame dont je dis oui c'est un
problème si je reviens des 8 il est
perdu le pion ouais ouais il est perdu
mais regardez autour des 8 forcé sinon
c'est d'un nain et la boum c6 sacrifice
de pions superbe ça c'est de ce joli
coup parce que puis on prend et forcé à
regarder parce que la bombe et l'on peut
pas prendre 17 ses protégés et si on
fait rien il va signer parce qu'il va y
avoir 6 7 et il y aura dame voilà donc
ça va ça va être ça va être pénible
voire même on peut aussi prendre un bain
bessette
enfin c'est l'horreur c'est 6 donc plus
on prend et là hop fou prend donc la cie
la tour bouge ces dames et si la tour
bouge pas il va y avoir foule bessette
et maintenant on peut pas empêcher le
pion à devenir dame mme bessette je
contrôle toutes les cases blanches ce
qui fait que j'allais il tout pouvoir de
deux des phases de ce fou et même de la
tour voile assez large contrôle toutes
les cases qui permet d'aller faire dame
les noirs jouent encore quelques coups
ses 517
ces quatre à six et la mariée à bouzy
touques abandonne cette partie qui qui
est vraiment perdu les blancs vont faire
dame alors ce pion là il va pas faire
dame jamais la question complètement
contrôlé donc ce championnat du monde se
termine par une superbe victoire de guy
fans ou par 3 à 0 au final bon même si
cette dernière victoire bien sûr est dû
au fait que les noirs ont tout tenté
pour revenir mais n'empêche que c'est
quand même assez clair donc le
classement est respectée et je crois que
bon on peut on peut saluer la
performance de l'ifan kyi qui n'a
vraiment pas été inquiété du match on
peut dire c'est à dire que même si maria
fait de belles parties vers la fin en
deuxième moitié de championnat
elle a posé des petits problèmes mais
jamais rien n'y a jamais rien eu de
vraiment décisif ça s'est joué à
peut-être moins l apal trouver les coups
les plus précis mais bon il feinte à
jouer quand même une grande facilité on
a le sentiment quand même que il ya
vraiment une classe d'écart entre les
deux joueuses on savait à priori au
départ étant donné la différence de
classement de 200 points hausse etc en
même assez assez important mais bon on
le voit l'arrivée de façon nette aussi
et à la fois dans le résultat est dans
le style voilà donc bravo bravo y lit
fans pour cette je crois que c'est la 3
ou 4e fois qu'elles qu'elles gagnent le
titre donc lé dominent les échecs
féminin et elle fait partie des
meilleurs joueurs du monde toute
catégorie puisqu'elle à 2660 et l'os
elle a déjà je crois athènes 2700
qu'elle fait partie des 50 cent
meilleurs du monde
donc elle et elle est vraiment voilà
elle est vraiment au top elle a joué le
tournoi aussi de devais creuser avec
tous les grands joueurs cette année avec
arsène y avait un homme veut y avait pas
non je crois pas non mais avec arsène y
avait il y avait du monde il y avait un
nid giry bon voilà donc est là elle a
fait aussi un tournoi bon difficile là
par contre la terminer un peu dans les
choux mais elle a fait elle a fait de
belles parties avec des joueurs de top
niveau mondial et elle a encore de quoi
progresser les jeunes voilà donc on
attend dans les prochaines années peut
être deux à réussir maintenant des
performances et bien dans les tons un
mixte et d'essayer d'arriver à faire
aussi bien pourquoi pas que judith pauli
alors pourquoi pas pourquoi pas c'est
tout le mal qu'on lui souhaite et c'est
ce qu'on espère pour pour sa progression
et notre plaisir de spectateur voilà
merci de m'avoir suivi donc sur les
modèles tv pour ce championnat du monde
féminin j'espère que ça vous a plu et
que bombay on essaiera de suivre les
moins je suis au moins les championnats
du monde comme l'avait vu et puis
quelques tournois intéressants
le long de l'eau de la saison voilà
merci de m'avoir suivi à bientôt à la
prochaine pour un autre événement sur
diagonale tv au revoir